It was becoming very clear that there are certain topics that you are not
allowed to research that you're not allowed to talk about or discuss,
even if you are a scientific expert in the field.
And one topic in particular that I had been following was the issue
of gender transition in children.
I'm Dave Rubin,
and this is the Rubin report as always guys make sure you're subscribed to our
YouTube channel and have clicked that pesky notification bell and joining me
today is a neuroscientist who specializes in gender sex and
sexual orientation, as well as the author of the new book,
the end of gender debunking the myths about sex and identity in
our society. Dr. Deborah. So welcome back to the Rubin report.
Hi Dave, thank you for having me again.
So I was checking right before I sat down to see when I had you on last and
it's, it's almost two years to the day. It's two years to the week.
And we were talking about much of the stuff that you wrote about in this book,
gender and the whole LGBT letter
conglomeration and identity and all of these things.
And I remember when we sat down for the first time that a lot of people said,
Oh no, this trans stuff, this isn't real, nobody really cares about this stuff.
All these things.
These are just made up things that only academics and you YouTube is care about
flash forward two years to where we're at right now with your book coming out
this week. And it's like, this is one of the biggest issues around.
So I guess my first question is it must feel pretty good to not be crazy, huh?
I guess so, but I've just so horrified by how everything has turned out. I mean,
I was really helped when I saw you two years ago.
I remember things were just starting to pick up in the mainstream and I was
still hoping there's still a chance maybe this is going to get caught.
People are going to figure things out.
We're going to be able to cut this off before it gets too crazy,
but it really has just gotten worse. And with the end of gender,
I wrote that book really with the hope of trying to, again,
bring more attention to these issues so that people might take them seriously
and realize that, you know, we're not just a bunch of fringe,
crazy people complaining about things.
These have real implications for people's lives, especially for young people.
And it's going to be really, really unfortunate and ugly in a few years.
Yeah. All right.
So the book is really spectacular and you dive into what are considered some of
the most controversial topics of the day.
So we're obviously going to get to all of that, but for,
for anyone watching this, that didn't see our first, uh, interview,
can you just do like a quick two minute sort of recap of your bio, of how,
of your training that led you to, to write this book?
Right. So I, when I was in my PhD,
so I have a PhD in sexual neuroscience research. I now work as a journalist.
I write predominantly about the science of sex and gender also about politics
and how politicization of scientific research is really doing society and a
disservice.
And I also write a lot about academic freedom because that's becoming an another
problem that we're seeing. And so for myself, and the last few years of my PhD,
I had noticed that the political climate of academia was shifting.
And it was becoming very clear that there are certain topics that you are not
allowed to research that you're not allowed to talk about or discuss,
even if you are a scientific expert in the field.
And one topic in particular that I had been following was the issue
of gender transition in children. And so at that time,
every single mainstream news piece,
pretty much I could count on maybe one or two fingers,
the number of pieces that had come out,
criticizing this at that time said that the best way for,
for children who are gender dysphoric.
So they feel they're more like the opposite sex than the sex that they were born
as the best way forward for them was to socially transition at a young age,
younger being better. And that once they did transition, they flourished,
you know, the parents would say that they're doing so much better,
but from a scientific perspective,
all of the research literature suggests that it's actually better for these
children to wait until they reached puberty. There's a very,
very high chance that they're going to outgrow the way they feel.
They're more likely grow up to be gay in adulthood.
And so I wrote an op-ed about this,
and I waited about six months because I didn't know if I really wanted to
publish it because I knew it was going to, there's going to be a huge backlash.
And I asked a number of my mentors and colleagues, what I should do.
And I remember one of my mentors said to me, I asked him,
should I wait until I have tenure?
Because at the time I had planned to stay in academia and I had a whole plan in
terms of what I was going to do in terms of my research.
And he said that tenure would not protect me in this climate.
So I decided to publish that piece. And it, it was, uh,
it was a difficult time. I'm really glad I did it.
And I write in the book about, you know,
what that process was like for me and what it was like being mobbed really badly
for the first time. But once you get through your first mobbing, you're fine.
And you know, they, they can't stop me now.
Yeah, it's funny because, uh, you know,
I've been through my own version of the mob thing and I feel the same way.
Once you get through it, you will survive. It's your it's going to hurt.
It's going to suck all of that stuff. But once you get through it and survive,
you will be stronger on the other side.
Could you just talk a little bit though about the reaction from
your colleagues because I'm still,
I think a lot of people can't accept somehow that academia could be this
corrupt,
that when you write a paper using scientific evidence saying that,
you know, when you transition this young,
it doesn't necessarily lead to a happier life and you use data and
evidence to support that, that you still get hit from the other academics.
Like I think people can't really the average person who's not in academia.
Can't really understand how that happened to academia.
Well, I would say within sex research, which was my discipline, um,
it really has been like a Canary in the coal mine because we saw these issues,
especially left-leaning science denial.
This has been an issue for decades in sexology,
which is the scientific study of sex and gender.
So most of us in sexology are liberals.
I consider myself still to be a and,
and I think my colleagues are just focused on doing good work as they should be.
So I wouldn't say not that you were saying this,
but I wouldn't say sex research necessarily themselves are corrupt in why they
stay silent. It's more that they know they already have a target on their back.
Usually sexologists are dealing from science now coming from the right.
Cause usually not everyone on the right is, is,
has an issue with sex researchers.
But historically has been more on the right now that it's coming from the left.
It's like sex researchers don't know how to deal with it because in a lot of
cases, it's people on the same side as you. And you're you feel as though, well,
is this really as important as calling out when the right comes after us?
So I think that's one layer of it. You know,
it's very competitive in academia and to get a tenure position is almost unheard
of nowadays. So you're very busy, it's stressful. And then,
then you have these other academics and other disciplines who are not
scientific, not to say that they all have bad intentions,
but they're starting to take over. They're the most vocal.
And they're getting a lot of support also,
I would say by mainstream news outlets. So it, as time goes on, it feels,
I think more and more like you have more to lose than to gain by speaking
out. So why start speaking out now? And that's where,
that's how we got to where we are.
So one of the things that I'm really amazed by,
and I've brought this up with a couple guests when I've talked about the trans
issue,
I've talked about this with Douglas Murray and with Rob Smith and a couple of
other people is that in many ways the trans movement now
seems almost perversely anti gay,
meaning that if you're in a feminine young boy,
they would rather see you transitioned to be female
rather than accept that you actually are just a gay male.
So I also think just for me personally,
it's particularly weird because I played with GI Joes and transformers. So the,
so no one thought I was gay per se, right? But if I,
but I have friends that played that were boys that played with Barbies and
people thought they were gay when, when they were five. And that if they now,
even though there may be in their forties now,
if they were growing up now and they were four years old,
five years old doing that, they would have been put through transition.
And that seems sort of anti gay, doesn't it.
A hundred percent, a hundred percent and myself,
as we talked last time I was with you. I grew up in the gay community.
I find this very upsetting.
You're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about academia
instead of nonstop, yelling out our academia playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist they're all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.